today we will be classifying this as a
variant of Interest that's eg.5 a
covid-19 subvariant that's being
discovered around the globe it's
effectively a cousin of the Omicron
variant experts say stronger variants
and subvariants are to be expected so
that means that this virus
directly can spread more possible faster
in the more pathogenic but virologists
say the new variant does not appear to
make people more sick epidemiologist Dr
prabha says there is no need to panic
their risk seems to be low but not zero
certainly of having something really
catastrophic is what has happened in the
past because we've built up hybrid
immunity still Public Health experts are
keeping a close eye on what covid and
other viruses are doing to prepare
themselves for the fall but what we will
have as we did last fall is call it a
try damage will have covid circulating
again we'll have seasonal flu and will
have RSV that also causes people uh
particularly the elderly or the young to
get sick experts say getting a booster
is one of the best lines of Defense
pediatric infectious disease physician
Dr Jesse papenberg is hopeful they will
be made available for even the youngest
Canadians currently in Canada there's
only the only products that are approved
for booster dose use are in children
five and above but we expect that by the
Fall Health Canada will approve also
products for those that are six months
of age and above until then experts say
washing your hands using masks and test
kits can go a long way we cannot predict
the future
but we can prepare for the future
Catherine Ward Global News Toronto